.
In the previous section we talked about
If we start with a rope
He took his left side
I can take the right side
And shake it
Spold is a kind of turbulence
In the rope
The turmoil seems so
Move the rope up and down
The disorder will move in the rope
He will move down the rope like this
They asked this in black
After the completion of the first session
Up and down
The thread will look like this
If we wait a little, the rope will look like this
Assuming I did this only once
The rope looks like this
Where the disturbance of the rope moved
This disorder is moved in the cord
In the previous section, we mentioned that the disorder
Moving in the rope
This medium (although no center is required)
The disorder is called: wave
Specifically this wave here is called a pulse
A pulse wave is called because we have one wave
One disorder in the rope
If repeated movement up and down
If done after regular intervals
The cord will look like
So
.
I try to draw clearly
It will look like this
As the unrest moves towards
right
You will move to the right at a certain speed
What I want to do in this section is to focus on
This type of wave. These waves are generated
At regular intervals
It moves up and down
With regular periodicity, we call it a periodic wave
This periodic wave, the movement is repeated after regular intervals
What I want to talk about is some characteristics
For the periodic wave, the first thing you might think of
What is the distance you move up and down
What after this movement from the point of silence?
If this is the place of equilibrium,
This movement is far from balanced
Above and below the point of equilibrium?
This distance is called: waveform.
This distance here,
Called wave amplitude
.
Some sailors have an idea of ​​the wave height
Wave height from the bottom
To the top of the wave
Capacity is of equilibrium position
to the top
Let me set the top
I think you know the meaning of the summit
The top is the highest point of the wave
This is the bottom
If you are in a fishing boat, you want to see the surge
You want to know the height
If your boat is here you'll be interested
This distance
In any case ,
This is the first idea
About the wave. Not all waves are generated by me
By moving the rope from the left side
But I think you understand the idea, that these waves represent
Multiple and different types
Of waves. This distance
From the position of equilibrium or from zero
Is the capacitance
The other question you may ask,
We knew the amplitude of the wave
But what is speed?
How long does it take you to move from position to equilibrium?
Then down and then back to equilibrium?
For each session What is the time period?
The cycle is the movement of the position of the balance up and down and return to the position of equilibrium again
What is the time period for each session?
What is periodic time?
We said it was a cyclical movement
Each cycle is a repeat of the previous one
Time to complete the cycle we call: periodic time
.
Time unit
The movement may be repeated every two seconds
Two seconds after completing a full course
Up and down
Two seconds
How much more complete cycle
every second ?
.
In other words, how much
Seconds per session
We can write this
.
For example, periodic time may be 5
Seconds per session
Or it may be 2 seconds per session
But what if the question is: how many cycles per second?
We ask the opposite question
Do not ask about the time period, how many seconds pass to complete the course
To complete the course
But, every second, how many times do you complete a cycle
How many cycles per second?
What is the number of cycles per second?
This is the reverse of periodic time.
The symbol for the periodic time is
T is great
The frequency
.
Symbolized by the symbol F
A cycle per second
If you take 5 seconds to complete the session, that means
You complete 1/5 session every second
All I did was turn the figure upside down
Which is logical
Because periodic time is inverted frequency
vice versa
Periodic time is the number of seconds per session
What is the time period to complete a cycle up and down?
Frequency is the time when a course is completed
Every second?
Periodic time inverted frequency
We can say that frequency is 1 on periodic time
Or we can say that periodic time is
1 on frequency
If I told you I was shaking the left side
From this rope,
The equivalent unit per second is the Hz
I can write this, 10 Hz
You probably heard this unit before
10 Hz means 10 cycles per second
If the frequency is 10 cycles per second, the periodic time will be
1 on 10
Permission 1 on 10 seconds per session
If I can complete 10 courses per second
Per second
It will take me ten seconds to complete one session
Another question that may be asked is what is the speed of the wave
In this case to the right
As I move the left side
What is the speed of his movement to the right?
Speed ​​is
We need to know the distance
Which the wave made after one cycle
After one session
After I moved this once, what is the distance?
What is the distance from this point of equilibrium?
To this point?
We call this distance: wavelength
.
There are many ways that you can define
Wavelength by
You can define the wavelength as the distance of the primary pulse
After completing one cycle
Or you can define it at a distance from a peak
To the top
This will be the wavelength as well
Or you can define it from distance to bottom
bottom
So too: wavelength
In general, you can define wavelength as
Distance from a certain point on the wave to
Same point on the adjacent wave
That is the wavelength
You complement this point to that
Complete a complete course
Then return to the same point
When I say back to the same point,
This point is not counted
Because this point even though we are in the same position
But we are heading down
We want to get to that point
We are in the same direction
Note here that we are moving up
We want to be heading up
This distance is not wavelength
For the wavelength
We should go back to the same point
Where we are in the same direction
This is also the wavelength
If we know the distance we go after one cycle
Wavelength is the distance
Which is interrupted by the wave after one cycle
.
Or after completing one cycle
Remember, periodic time is the time period
To complete one session
Up and down
If we know the distance, we have learned time
How can we know
the speed ?
Well, speed is the distance over time
.
For waves: speed
I can use vectors but I think you understand the general idea
Speed ​​is
Distance traveled after one cycle
The distance traveled is wavelength
After completing a full course
The wave will be cut off exactly this distance
This is the wavelength
And what time is
To complete this distance?
It will take me one periodic period to complete this distance
Speed ​​is the wavelength on periodic time
.
Well I just said that 1 on periodic time is
Frequency
I can write speed as wavelength
For clarification
The symbol used for the wavelength is
Latin letter: lambda
We can say that speed is equal
Wavelength on periodic time
It is also wavelength
Hit 1 on periodic time
We said that 1 on periodic time is
Frequency
So speed is
Frequency wavelength multiplexing
If you know this, you can solve all the issues
Which belong to waves
For example, if you know that
I have a speed of 100 meters per second
To the right
And that frequency is
20 cycles per
S, or 20 Hz
If this is the information that
Know about wave motion
For this rope
20 Hz means that you are in one second
You'll see this rope vibrate up and down twenty times
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17
18 19 20
In one second
You will see the vibration twenty times
That's what we mean by 20 Hz
20 cycles per second
Data is speed
Frequency
What is wavelength?
Wavelength in this case
The speed is equal to the wavelength hit
Frequency
Divide the parties on 20
Let's put units
The speed is in meters per second, equal to 20 lambda
Cycle per second
If you divide both parties on 20 cycles per second you will get
100 meters per second multiply 1/20 seconds per cycle
The output becomes 5
This becomes 1
Seconds are canceled
You get 5 meters per session
5 meters per session
Is the wavelength of this example
The wavelength is 5 meters
You can say 5 meters per cycle, but the wavelength symbolizes
Distance per session
In this case if the movement is to the right at 100 speed
Meters per second and frequency
20 cycles per second, this is the distance
5 meters
We can easily calculate periodic time
The cycle time will be 1 on frequency
1/20 seconds per session
Using these formulas, I do not want you to save them
But to be understood and logical to you
In the hope that the passage will be clear and useful
Using these formulas you can solve all the questions
By knowing the value of only two variables
To find the rest of the values
Anyway, I hope you find this useful